one nation under God indivisible with
uh
I hope you all had a chance to read the
write-up that the Secretary of State's
office gave us last week
I actually found it pretty interesting
and
it
kind of put my my thoughts I'm starting
to get a feeling of what maybe we could
accomplish here you know something
I like to find the areas of agreement
when I'm working with people you know
focus on that first because
the areas of disagreement will always
take care of themselves right
but uh when I was looking at this
write-up
it it made me start to think that in
addition to policy matters in which we
expect some disagreement though some
agreement as well it seems like there's
a
I don't want to say issues a lot of
aspects of the current
statutes that ought to be we could all
be able to agree need to be fixed
and so it should be easy to become seems
to me should be relatively easy to come
to an agreement on some simple stuff
like like the question that he brought
up about
the difference between
candidates filing as a candidate and
filing as a candidate committee you
mentioned that in the notes that you
sent me too
uh
where they have different uh reporting
deadlines in a couple of instances
I mean it seems to me that should be
something it should be
relatively straightforward to bring into
agreement between a candidate committee
and someone running just as a candidate
I asked that because when I'm speaking
it always makes sense to me so I want to
yeah so go ahead do we require
candidates to have a candidate committee
before so I guess my question is do we
as a group want to require candidates to
file as a committee or still give them
the chance to file only as a candidate
and I don't understand the advantage of
the disadvantage either way but I was I
was thinking about that you might
remember that last year or the year
before this there was a proposal to
require
all candidates including State Rep
candidates to form a committee and
at that time and I haven't changed my
mind I really don't think we should try
to fit everyone into that box because a
lot of you know we've got 400 State reps
uh
and a lot of our campaigns are pretty
simple to run and don't really require
more than one person who who can accept
financial responsibility you know fiscal
responsibility
uh
so my feeling is no we don't need to
require
a candidate committee certainly not the
State Rep level but
I was thinking as I was
as I was reading this these notes from
the secretary of state that
well I still think if a campaign is on a
large enough scale maybe if state senate
race qualifies for that by large scale I
I mean really
substantial large amounts of money
amounts of money would all agree are
substantial I mean I I understand that
some State Senate races can run what a
hundred thousand or a lot more I mean to
me that's real money
as well to me a quarter is a real real
money but but you know that's that's
serious money where
as a candidate especially running for
the first time you might want some
some people helping you officially that
uh familiar with the ins and outs of
running such a campaign so I think we
should still allow the opportunity
so I think
being able to run as solely as a
candidate or having a candidate
committee still make sense to me
but bringing just picking on one issue
is an exam as an example of something I
think we should be able to agree on
having those reporting deadlines the
same
uh I think it's the
the two deadlines
in the uh off here the odd numbered year
where the candidate committees have to
report
file a report in June and December
and someone running who's
still filed is registered as just a
candidate does it in May and November
why shouldn't those be the same
I can't think of a good reason
is it that's something that
I think would help reduce uh
confusion basically on the part of the
the candidates and the people working
with them
so that's that's there's one example of
something I think we should be able to
agree on there's a number of others here
too
so I'm
are you saying that the only times they
would been a file would be uh May and
December no I was I was looking at the
table in this write-up of the filing uh
deadlines and it looked like there were
only two that were different between
uh it's on they're on page seven and
eight
there of this this write-up that they
uh
let's see uh
it looks like there's three actually
too late to do anything but a June
filing deadline for the candidate
committees that does not apply to the
candidates at the top of page seven
so again there's lots more to discuss
but
this
is establishing the idea that we can
find things we can all agree on
and
my thinking is that that would probably
be a really good place to start
maybe we'll get in the habit of agreeing
[Laughter]
so those are my thoughts right now the
the thoughts that from the front of my
I mean I didn't have a strong opinion
either way I never really understood the
difference you know why you would do it
I just felt like for my own race I mean
it was so small it didn't make sense to
do a committee and I wasn't going to
raise a ton of money that kind of thing
but so I didn't do it but if if you're
running for Senate or executive Council
Governor I mean you need somebody to do
that I agree with that I just didn't
know we we're trying to streamline
things would did we want everybody to be
a committee but as long as we're making
them report I don't see that it makes
that much difference I can be convinced
otherwise but
foreign
just like to review the argument for
simplifying by having everybody register
as a candidate committee versus the
present form which you said you you
prefer where candidates have the option
of being just a candidate and not having
a candidate committee so there was that
bill you mentioned earlier that would
make everybody register as a candidate
committee right and what's the argument
for that what's the argument against it
I actually don't remember the argument
for except maybe a simplification one
but I don't think it's that complicated
the way we're doing it now the argument
against it from my own personal
a campaign that's
State Rep a campaign does not have to be
terribly complicated
you put out signs maybe you put a few
ads in you your door knock we all know
the routine
and to to be required to find somebody
else who will officially sign up and
participate in that campaign is just
it's just it's almost like another
barrier to participation
for the reports uh yeah I can't see any
right
and
confusion and the discussion we had last
week with the
Secretary of State and
they seem to think that would make sense
also they couldn't they didn't they were
bringing this to our attention as
something that could be improved I think
again this is just one example as I was
and I'm really I was really happy they
gave us a handout because trying to take
adequate notes while listening it can be
difficult
so how would you guys like to hand oh uh
were you here a few minutes ago when I
was since yeah yeah when I was
suggesting that we hold the next meeting
two weeks from today
yeah okay
I have another question or point about
candidate candidate committee please on
page six of the um handout from the
Secretary of State's office last week
right oh excuse me just under number
three reporting deadlines because I
guess what we're talking about
um
the end of the first paragraph says this
distinction
on when the first report is due is
another area where 664 is complex
requires deep understandable is that
what we're addressing right now or is
this a different issue that that's
we're we're
addressing I think of a specific aspect
of the general issue of complexity
when it comes to political committees
right now yes in one particular aspect
of that there's other aspects that we
could look at as well again I was just
trying to come up with an example of
establish the point that we can agree on
things
I have the same recording requirements
right
and
based on my reading and my Recollections
of last week's meeting there's a a
number of things like this that would
uh
you know we could there are
contradictions in the statutes as
currently written that I think we could
we were we were listening to The Experts
last week and
it was
the Secretary of State's office it was
clear they were aspects of the statutes
that they're not quite sure what they
mean
which is not a good thing
see in my mind right now I'm splitting
the subject matter into like two broad
areas one
is of course the policy questions you
know thresholds for reporting and so on
that that's a policy matter
but whatever policies we
agree on
uh there's a separate issue which is
whatever is in the statute should be
understandable
right
oh that's right you're you're in that
professions I'm sure you see many
examples in yeah where things are not
clear
okay so can I take Advan Advantage
having
State here
for a minute yes you can if she's
willing to discuss things with us yeah I
guess you do have to but this we're
trying to let me let me introduce her
okay deputy secretary of state Aaron
Hennessy
thank you for joining us
the Attorney General's office to come
and address us on issues with no success
so we'd like to enlist someone's help if
we if that makes sense and if you're if
they're comfortable doing it and helping
us reach out to the AG and have them
come and do a presentation the way last
week that Secretary of State and
um Mr Finch pitched in so
I'm happy to reach out to their office
okay thank you
well thank you
well we we had a very good discussion
with uh
Mr Scanlon and Mr Stitch last week
and we but we we know that uh
we need to talk to the people
responsible for enforcing
the campaign Finance system laws
back we were I think reminded of that
several times in that discussion
so thank you any help would be
appreciated
well you you did send the did you want
yeah okay sure if you'd like to share it
sure
uh representative Lane prepared a list
of
the things that caught her eye and
and reading the Secretary of State's
write-up
it was not quite as organized I made my
was there anything uh
representative Muirhead that you've had
or approach you'd like to take
why I agree with your approach and uh
um
I do think it'd be good to have a list
of of
um
unnecessary complexities and sources of
confusion that were highlighted by the
Secretary of State
uh Mr Fitch last week
um and even if we had that list even
prior to knowing whether we agree
right that every element of that list
can be you know corrected in ways that
are common sensible that would be useful
right okay maybe that's what
yeah I mean I I read what she sent to me
last night and it was a
a good summary of her take on
on things like that and mixed in with
some policy matters but
I saw uh
you know some amount of overlap between
what she had picked up on and what I
Russia
right
uh nothing significant in the brief time
you were absent
I might have missed something on my list
in other words oh yes this may not I
might have overlooked something it was
if I did it was uh not intentional
foreign
okay
so how would you like to approach this
because I'm thinking maybe we take this
right up and just do a once over
together
kind of like we did with the definitions
a couple of weeks ago
and I've got my notes on my write-up and
we've got your
helpful list that'll maybe help us Focus
uh the first
thing that kind of strikes my mind
strikes me as
the first line we have nine different
types of registration
or political
um
we've discussed candidate committees in
registering as a candidate
and shared our views on that
uh
are there any of those
other seven that
seem like they could be streamlined or
subsumed into another category to you
guys
work on
[Music]
honors and independent expenditures we
might be able to eliminate those and
then
um
how we look at what a candidate is and
you can look at the way I think where
the way I'm told is that in federal law
they look at what the major purpose of
an organization is and if the major
purpose is supporting that candidate
then
um that you can so it's basic and then
anything that's not a major purpose and
that would be the Super Pacs and those
you would have them record when they
expend money or or when they hit a
certain level
at least that's the way I understand it
so it you could have the definition of a
political committee
just be much more General than what
we've got here and then tie it to what
they're expending and these are
how people expand and these are
categories at least when when I read
stuff about campaign finance and I I
actually read a couple different state
statutes just to get an idea you know
how they do it and is it it's not that
different than how we're doing it here
but to streamline it you would just make
the definition of political committee as
generic as you can and tie the
distinction to either the major purpose
of it or the expenditures in the
independent expenditures but then
because a Super PAC
at least is a type of pack
but it's the pack is organized to
support usually the candidate and is
tied to the candidate a Super PAC is not
okay so you have to be clear about
um coordination and what constitutes
coordination and I think that's what
Ross was getting to because he didn't
like the super Pacs coming in he wanted
to make sure that we had coordination
because it's not defined right now in
our statute what coordination is
so
I'm kind of rambling but I think there's
a way to do it I just haven't set pen to
well with what we're doing here certain
amount of brainstorming is going to be
helpful
seems to me
well
now
two and three candidate committee and
I mean we know well there was there was
a
there was one
detail in the reporting periods that I
thought should be straightforward to fix
and it it mentions in a couple of places
where the language is uh
in one place a couple of places in the
statutes
for what is reported
by a reporting deadline let's say the
reporting you have to get the report in
by the end of Wednesday
and in some places in the statutes it
says it will include
all activity
reportable activity up to and including
uh
Monday another places it says up to
Monday I think that's uh the two ways of
saying it
and that's a bit ambiguous I mean up to
including makes it very clear
it would be through Monday
up to might
strictly speaking include only through
Sunday
correct so that seems like an incon
that's an inconsistency that I think
should be
six Roman numeral two dash a right yep
uh it's footnote number two
yeah
oh okay
664 colon six Roman numeral two and six
sixty four six Roman numeral one
when I was filing my reports I just
assumed it was through Monday
and two days later you filed the report
I was not aware of this inconsistency
well
and and I think
so so do you want to make it include
Monday or not I I don't do people have
time to I mean is that too much to ask
not maybe not so much for the larger
campaigns but
for the 400 of us that don't have larger
campaigns is that or do you want to cut
it off on Sunday
I don't actually have a preference I
just think it should be one or the other
so
someday
and then there's a lot of different
dollar amounts I guess we can talk about
that at some point trying to make the
dollar amounts as consistent as possible
but we might not be able to do that
right when you start we start talking
about dollar amounts that's starting to
be a policy thing right and I'm not
saying we shouldn't talk about them I'm
just saying let's do these things the
easy things yeah do do the things we
think we're likely to agree on because
resolving an inconsistency in two parts
of the statute on what the cutoff is I
actually think that's pretty important
there was a
an example of an inconsistency in the
statutes back in 2000 I think it was
2017.
uh it was a
really severe winter storm on Town
election day
uh I think the first two people remember
that right
and a significant proportion of the Town
moderators in the affected areas
read one portion of the statute that
made it sound very clear that they had
the authority to delay the election
a postponed the election because of
severe weather
and there was a another
statute
that
stated
that the towns were required to hold the
election on that particular day you all
remember that
and the Secretary of State came down
Secretary of State Gardner
it was his
uh
controlling opinion that it was the
latter it was had to be on Tuesday
so that how long did it take to were you
in the legislation yeah hello that take
I was a selectman and I it took us I
think most of the year
right to get a bill passed that where
the select where the Selectmen had to
say yes this was a valid election took
in a round I had not been a legislator
when that happened but the next year oh
and we came up with a bill that that
supposedly fixed it but
um it that was that was a dance too so
well in the town election we had
recently in early March it happened
again
it happened again and the the moderators
had the clear authority to postpone
right
it was a good thing because I had over
in fact I was still digging out on there
and couldn't make our postpone election
so anyway so there's an exam there's an
example of why consistency between the
statutes is important we all knew this
but I think of that every time I look at
and
I I see I mean there are some of us who
do pay attention to details and for
people like that where the details don't
match up it can be a barrier too to
getting involved we don't want that
all right so there's one
okay
so reporting deadlines
number three on Page Six
I think that's what Russia were reading
yeah he was talking about I think
um
Mr Fitch was talking about how it's a
two-pronged test you have to you have to
form and spin
okay
do not have a duty to register unless
I don't know the
I will go through my notes before our
next meeting and come up with a nice
list like you did right
[Music]
Marshall that's when they have to and
like you said the pilot that gets into
policy
about the number but we can we agree
that once we hit a number
when they either hit a number of
expenditures or donors
then they have to start reporting or is
it just expenditures because if we're
working on transparency
we're really trying to find out what
they're spending right
so if they've collected a lot of money
but they're not spending it
I don't know no I know what you're
I'm thinking
and I don't have a real solid opinion on
this yet so I'm just kind of yeah
thinking out loud I mean they're both
uh
your your thoughts on what was you know
the purpose of campaign Finance system
mine were a little
uh simpler than yours but there was some
and I'm still thinking this through but
yeah the purpose of
we know that in our election system
I go back right to the the root of the
legitimacy of our former government
which is it's it's laid out in the
Declaration of Independence
that the just powers of governments uh
derive from the consent of the
government that's self-evident according
to the founders there's not something to
discuss or argue it's self-evident you
don't have to prove it
I like that I like when they're making
it clear where they're starting from so
it depends on the consent of the
government and our election law system
is how we go about ensuring we have that
consent right that makes sense
but
you know what requirements does the
election law system have to fulfill in
order to do that well I see two broad
categories
well
we need to make an accurate assessment
of the sentiment of the
the voting public you know the people
who have the franchise
and we have to do it in such a way that
we retain their confidence that it's
that it is accurate
and to do it accurately
well one of the things required to
retain the confidence is that this
system
be transparent so and by that I mean
people can readily understand what's
going on and I can see campaign finances
coming under that requirement the need
for transparency and specifically it
kicks in
uh
uh undue influence I think that was
kind of at the heart of what we're
concerned about
and
particularly we we don't want there to
be covert
undue influence if somebody is pumping
enough money into a particular political
effort
that the money itself might be
influencing
uh the actions of the
candidate
I don't know that we can stop that but
we've the public should know about it
so that's that's what I that's how I see
it here preventing undoing
making sure everybody's aware if there's
a possibility of undue influence well
that's our requirement right and the
amounts of money involved of course
that's that's where it gets to be policy
what is that amount of money and there's
there's room for reasonable people that
disagree on that too
I think an estate representative Race
For example where we're
we're making a hundred dollars a year
before taxes
and I don't think there are very many of
the 400 that are or of the 24 senators
are doing it for direct financial
reasons I think it's so maybe the
threshold makes sense for those
thresholds reporting to be lower
uh
higher level you know uh
levels of uh races that involve more
constituents for the candidate
and hence more money to reach them
and those those thresholds are different
right
right so the principle of having
thresholds
I think we can agree on but then the
it becomes a question of finding the
amount we can agree on yep
I expect we could have lots of
discussion on we have in the past right
so I'm still looking for easy pickups
here I guess okay uh one question
something that's unclear to me
uh
what is the date range that applies to a
given election cycle we see that you had
that question too in your list yeah and
I had the same question I mean I would
like an answer to it
uh we hear about election cycle quite a
bit but I haven't seen a definition as
to when a particular two-year we know
it's two years because elections are
every two years when does the previous
election cycle in what date
is that defined anywhere I haven't seen
it in our statute no action cycle or
election it's not but I I mean for me
and I I know that Ross we we talked
about misconcerns about paying off you
know loans and stuff like that but yeah
we could do that the election cycle
starts the day after the general
election
the next cycle okay the next like so the
it's the election cycle
what gets confusing however is what
happens in that situation where you're
still out there campaigning after you
win
and you get money to pay off your loan
how do you where what money is that
going to is that going to the new one or
is it going to the old one
or do we say if it's going towards
expenditures that were made
and let's say 22 right I understand
then it would be for the previous
election cycle if it's going to go
towards 24
that's the next one right right yeah
then you it would you'd have to put it
there in that one as a donation
so it would it would I guess be for
expenditures that were made during that
election cycle
I think that works but I don't know for
sure and I still don't know what to do
with excess but we can talk about that
later
but that's one definition that I've seen
and it kind of also encompasses
if you're doing the exploratory or if
you're starting to because people start
campaigning well before June when we
have to file well with a with a two-year
cycle it's yeah you know when does the
campaigning really stop especially for
the the races with more constituents yes
you know State Senate and yeah yeah in
theory while running we're running now
but
I'm not knocking on doors yet
so
but anyway that was one
that I saw sometimes they do it
I was looking at like I said some of
these other statutes I'll look at some
of the other ones again and see how they
Define it but that one kind of stuck out
and it seemed easy
to do yeah I'm
I think I was thinking about this also
I was
and I understood the concern we
discussed the thought we discussed last
week which had to do with generating
additional Surplus after election day
which then is not accounted for in
contribution can be rolled over to the
uh
I'm not going to use the term loophole
because I kind of
I just hear that too much I guess to me
it's if something is within the law it's
within I'm not a lawyer so maybe I'm
simple minded on this but if it's within
the law it should be considered within
the law
and it's not actionable by the
government now people can have their
opinion on it that's a whole you have a
right to opinions but
but anyway
uh I understand the question we
discussed last week about someone keeps
accepting donations after election day
and builds a larger Surplus
maybe that would be a way to approach it
if you have
a debt
people should be able to raise funds to
pay off that debt
uh if they can't pay off a debt with
donations after election day that that
could also be a barrier to people of
maybe it would make sense to say you
you can't accumulate any additional
it's just this is just like the
beginnings of a thought
had to look at if I'd have to look at it
from a lot of different angles before I
concluded it made sense but it's it's
maybe an approach
if you have a debt to pay off
you can collect and
on on the previous election cycle you
can accept donations until you've paid
the debt off and then from then on they
have to go into the next cycle
which would be the current cycle after
election day is that making okay
yeah okay let's
either be an expenditure or it was
incurred I guess in other words you
might incur it but not have yet paid for
it
so it depends on how you define your
expenditure but I think you know I think
we're thinking along the same lines yeah
I would I would myself and I'm not a
lawyer
uh in engineering we try to think
logically too to do yes you do
some of my favorite clients
uh
to me an expense is when you've incurred
the obligation to pay the money that's
really the date of the expense in my
mind
again I'm obviously not a financer
Finance year
but that's maybe an approach that we
so
the thought that the
election cycle would end
at midnight on Election Day
in the next cycle then begins
okay and uh
it
I'm also looking for things that would
uh not just
that we could agree on but that we could
get
the other
394 or 395 representatives to agree on
or a majority of them
that's right and yeah and and then
there's a another chambers of
well this is my second year doing it I I
will just decide I do think that bills
that come through the New Hampshire
legislature get thoroughly vetted
we look at them in many different ways
and I think that's a good thing that's
obviously a good thing
all right
okay
and then how
like so going through his list
okay and then what to do with the
Surplus I guess is at the bottom of page
it's interesting it's only a political
committee it doesn't say or candidate
page eight
oh
[Music]
what was it about that that has your
attention
what was just the theory that that was
in this memo that has some
on the next page right goes through
different complexities or issues and I
just
and then if you have an access and you
roll it over and you're allowed to roll
it over
um
how do you attribute that
um and do you have to do you have to
attribute it
so say it's five thousand dollars do you
have to look back and say this the money
is all co-mingled now so you don't know
who gave you that money you don't know
where did that 5000 come did it come
from several one thousand did it come
from you know a number of small
donations where did it come from and do
you have to attribute it to somebody to
figure out what the limits are if you
roll it over do you have to attribute it
or do you just start with that campaign
War chest
and not attributed to anybody and that's
where you start for the next election I
I don't know I but I would think it
might be a nightmare trying to figure
out where it came from at least I think
I don't think it would be for the small
campaigns it would be it's not
it's not the least bit practical and I'm
I was thinking about this one as well
and I don't know that
there's any purpose to it because the
donations the contributions they
received in the previous
election cycle that
we're above the threshold for uh you
know reporting the name of the person
that's still on record
so someone who was particularly
concerned and they may and the bigger
campaigns especially there
could be uh
they can trace that back the history
doesn't just go away
they can see they can look over
a number of election Cycles you can look
for patterns you can see who were big
donors in the past so I'm not sure it's
needed because that history is still
there of who donated
that make yeah
the pains I just tried to go back trying
to go back I mean would be
I don't know what you guys think but I
think it would be really hard
well I'm talking about the public has
access to the records from the previous
campaign cycle so that can the the who
the donors were that knowledge still
exist in an accessible form and then
they then just start a clean slate
for the next election for the
distribution limit
yeah I think so yeah
[Music]
because again those previous records of
who were contributing
monies we think
we we agree surpass the threshold of
people should know who did it that still
exists
so I don't think we need to split it out
plus it's totally impractical there's no
particular benefit
because the knowledge still exists who
contributed
in order to file a final report and is
there some reason that we're doing
that
I'm I'm thinking there's two aspects to
the campaign Finance system uh
reporting
one we've discussed which is
trying to make sure that the public has
knowledge whether could be undo what we
call undue influence
another reason I think
is also
that
the fact that a campaign has to account
for the funds
publicly in reports is protection for
contributors
I donate
right a hundred dollars you know big
money you know well for me it would be
it would right for all of us I think but
it assures
the fact you have to zero it out and
account for how the money was disposed
of for example you can zero it out if
you have a surplus and you donate it to
another campaign or you donate it I
believe to a charity and recognized
charity right so the people who
uh donated now know the money was used
for a proper purpose
that they had in mind when they donated
it
so in New Hampshire at least right you
build up a big campaign War chest you
can't go uh you're no longer running for
office you can't go spend it on a
vacation on a cruise
right
so I think that's the second aspect of
it and why it's important to zero it out
before you close it
you roll it over to that
I guess if you decide not to run you'd
still have to zero it out you'd have to
see right out at that time and one of
the
passions Allowed by the law and that's
also a protection against corruption
exactly that's why I think it's an
excellent protection against corruption
you can't you can't build up a huge War
chest and then I'm not running anymore
and spend it however you like which
would be
corrupt
if the money I'm speaking you know
generally and loosely no I agree
so that's a good reason for zeroing out
a particular
yes what's on your mind representative
um just looking at the at the
Secretary of State's
um
list that he shared with us last week
um there seemed to be a number like a
lot a lot of things that this working
group could look into one just taking
them in order
um that the can a candidate committee is
undefined
um and so uh on page one
of 11
number two a last sentence if retained
as a separate type of registration quote
candidate committee should be defined so
if we want to retain that we should
maybe write a definition of it that we
could insert into the law
two I mean the second thing that I see
here
um
there are different reporting
requirements for candidate committees
and candidates you've already mentioned
that candidate committee has to register
within 48 Hours of promoting success or
defeat
um a candidate only has to register when
expenses are greater than a thousand
dollars right
um the two things should be the the
reporting requirement should just be the
same for these two things probably
three third thing
on page two of eleven
in the discussion of
exploratory candidate candidates
exploratory candidates do not need to
register at all they can raise and spend
without limit
and the Secretary of State's memo
says to us at the bottom of the third
paragraph on page two exploratory
um
exploratory candidates committee should
be defined in the reporting obligation
should be made explicit last sentence of
the third paragraph
uh one idea is to well there are
different solutions to that but I'm just
this is just on the to-do list so I
don't I won't segue into Solutions but
but the third item on the to-do list
um fourth item
um
turning to the
next page three of eleven number five
political committee major purpose and
electioneering
there's a twenty five hundred dollar
trigger here
receipts or expenditures totaling twenty
five hundred dollars I think there's an
ambiguity
because the candidate committee has a
thousand dollar
and the candidate has a thousand dollar
trigger
so we have just a different number here
without getting into the question what
the number should be just we might want
to
settle our it'd be good if there were
consensus that the numbers should be
different if they are different
or or would ideally be the same whatever
the same number is
um
there's this Distinction on page three
between these two types major purpose
electioneering major purpose not
electioneering
um whether it's not electioneering that
that the threshold is five thousand
dollars in a calendar year
um
and so again you have a different number
and it's not and I guess there's no
definition in the law of
okay next to do list from this uh page
four
of 11 item nine political advocacy
organizations to be discussed
um I think that there's a
um
need to clarify this category if we wish
to keep it and there are further
items seven and eight on political
advocacy or organization where the memo
directs us to RSA 6642 section 22.
um
and they're and they're just ambiguities
there in this category one in this one
of eight categories political advocacy
organization so
um again it has a five thousand dollar
trigger maybe we just need to sort out
do we want this to be in the law this
this category and is it what you know be
good to know what purpose it's serving
um The Entity of political advocacy
organization yeah yeah that that
that's the kind of thing that when I
read that
I feel kind of wary of because I think
we're all very uh
adamant about the Free Speech rights
protected by the First Amendment and
something sometimes my antenna I just
start to quiver about whether we're
verging on that like like a political
advocacy advocacy organization we've got
a right to say whatever we want about
political matters too and we have a
right to associate with other people to
do that
so so we should so we should read the go
back to that 6642 section 22 with the
real what what the Secretary of State's
memo speculates on page 10 number seven
um you know this I'll just read that to
you definition of political advocac
story yeah I think it's the organization
is not easily understood I think that
might be an understatement one
reasonable construction of the
definition
what page are you reading from oh page
11 page 10 sorry what
um item number seven on page ten ah okay
thank you which just directs it's a
continuation of this discussion
political advocacy organization but it
directs us to the put parts of the RSA
where they're not defined oh right you
can one reasonable construction is that
a registered can is this is kind of a
catch-all thing if the other seven
things didn't catch you this one is
there to catch you so it's it's a
registered can can choose this only if
you don't qualify as any of the other
types of registration
so so maybe that's what the purpose is
I'm just speculating here but anyway it
seems like we have some defining to do
if we want to keep that
um yeah there was a there was another
political committee type on page four
item seven political committee voluntary
registration
is that
yeah they don't have well they don't
have to report but they don't
first I understand what it is but why do
we need that so so there are these other
um I don't know that we do back well
back later in the memo yeah
um there are these cases where people
entities or people register though
they're not required to sometimes
because they're receiving a contribution
and the contributor wants to know that
the contribution has been received and
registered well I I know I read that
okay and I understand it but
I don't know how to put this nicely is
that really our problem that we need to
address in the law I don't know I don't
know I don't have a real opinion on it
it's a question yeah good it's a really
good question maybe the system could
allow people to do it without it being
in the RSA
the next thing on the to-do list is that
Fiscal Agent fiscal
oh right versus Financial agent Fiscal
Agent and Treasurer yeah and 664-12
6647 they they're we have different
terms floating around 664 3 and 13.
um and uh
secretary of state reports on page six
of the memo we receive questions on the
distinction between Financial agent
Fiscal Agent Treasurer clarifying these
roles in any intended distinction would
be beneficial if there's no meaningful
distinction
you might not use a single term so
um
yep
the there's another next item on the to
do so the eighth item on my list of the
to Do's in this memo
um arises on page eight of the memo
um
where uh the reporting requirements
for
um
reporting deadlines are being discussed
and
and there's a question about the
reporting requirements
um
for for political committees
that doesn't that don't have
contributions or or receipts in excess
of a thousand dollars
um
but that's on page eight
yeah page eight at the end of the first
paragraph some filers find the
requirement and process for the zero
receipt expenditure reports confusing
just just of note so if we want that to
be confusing we want the law to be
confusing we should keep it as it is
maybe if we want to fix that
um then there's the next paragraph
there's a way in which committees are
reporting twice so the end of that
paragraph says record reporting twice is
the current practice in order to comply
at the loss so probably you don't really
need to make people report you know the
intention isn't to make them report
twice I had the same question in my
notes yeah so that's a mop up area
um and page nine it looks like on item
4A at the top
um
this has to do with closing I think
closing out a political committee
um this this item a
right
so yeah it says the plain language would
mean that even though they've never had
to report right the deadlines leading up
to and following the election they would
nonetheless have to file a report
disposing all receipts and expenditures
to close the committee right because
they exist as a committee even though
they
under another definition yes it's a
small thing but it's a source of
complete confusion and then finally the
last to do thing is raising funds after
a cycle if there's no debt in the
campaign and the Secretary of State's
memo on page nine down
um
on letter d
asks that we make more explicit the
prohibition against post-election
fundraising and campaigns we were just
discussing that a while ago which
those are just that's my list for as for
what's on my mind of the to Do's that
come out of this memo none of which I
think necessarily involve
you know essentially contested
um ideas and Concepts and philosophies
is that something you would be willing
to take a few minutes and type up as a
working as a working document yeah I'll
who's who's maintaining like
writing all of these do we just start
having a working document and then
insert stuff for
but
I started doing it only because that's
how I think well that's all I think I
just hadn't got to it yet yeah I mean
I've made my notes on okay on the
write-up I think I mean I will make a
similar list myself I need to
so I can think about it okay uh I think
we can I think we can share these These
are this is not an actual document in
the public sense because it's not it's
just notes
okay uh
and I'm and as I look ahead there's a
lot there and and some of those things
are very very
uh require a lot of concentration study
and maybe this committee picks out
you know two or three of them and tries
to do on the on the idea that fixing
something is better than fixing nothing
even if we can't fix everything
well what's that saying progress not
perfection
right I mean make things better
well in our that implies in our opinion
of course it would have to be an opinion
shared by a majority of
two legislative Chambers too to go
anywhere
so
yeah that's that's what I was thinking
when I read through this and considering
the policy matters that
that we could also discuss
yeah as far as yeah I don't know that
we're under
I think there's a natural deadline for
what we're doing here not a natural
schedule
uh what's the date by which legislation
would have to be filed for next year I
don't remember since December
does it
right about later September oh it is
that soon okay I thought it was later I
I'm glad I'm glad we have you guys here
thank you
wow that's that's soon
yeah
I just don't have it with me
recommended legislation of Canada to the
next
I mean that would still be good work you
don't have to necessarily get the same
well actually if we wanted if we got to
the point where we had
Notions that we thought were ready to
introduce his legislation that would be
the schedule but we still can produce a
useful work product in the form of a
report right laying out more
recommendations than that yeah and the
reasons you know and supporting
uh
material to support why we think that of
course
and the deputy secretary of state raised
her hand with a con I think she might
have a comment
we would welcome your comment Deputy a
would you like to come up to the
microphone just so we can all hear
okay
Aaron Hennessey deputy secretary of
state this is just a tip trick from my
old legislative days if not as my
current role but if there are things
that you know you want to change you
could put a bill in September and if you
want to continue working you could amend
that bill that's what I was wondering
well um
right I'm still thinking we can come up
with at least a list of topics that
would improve the current state of the
statutes it would be helpful to people
at the end of this year or would it
continue then we could continue on and
put in that amendment I don't know
we can find out though I don't recall
that it was an end date included in the
notice of the subcommittee yeah I don't
know if there was a yeah I don't know if
and I don't know when they appointed the
subcommittee they had that same date so
I guess we can clarify that
yeah yeah there may well be a rule on
that I don't know what okay we can find
out though
all right let me make a note on that
does this subcommittee have a defined
yeah that that another
area on my mind has to do with
exploratory committees and the
that implies a certain formality but
anybody can consider whether they want
to run for office ahead of the filing
period and they can talk to people about
it
and people can promote their own ideas
through media you know paid media even
without having to ask permission
so
it doesn't sound like we have a
definition of exploratory candidate do
we
I mean it's not in there it would have
to be one that wouldn't be used but it's
clearly defining and if there were one
that would have would have to be sure it
doesn't step on people's Free Speech
rights
for the entire election cycle yep it's
but we would have to Define when you
become a candidate
which we have to do anyway which is
defined for they wanted us to Define
when when you become a candidate so I'll
I'll take that on but when you do but
when do you start running and the
Secretary of State suggested the date
that you file
that that's in June and you probably
already been collecting money and
campaigning and doing stuff particularly
for the larger offices well before the
date that you file sure so I'm not sure
that that date is really capturing what
we want to know
so if so I think but it would be in an
election cycle so it would catch it if
we Define an election cycle I think
I just
so if we go with Ross's idea we'd have
to bump up the limits but it would it
would still be the same amount of money
it's just not divided into those three
exploratory primary
in general and that would be simpler and
I'm not sure why we should just
why we need to or should distinguish
especially if something is difficult to
Define
do we really need to do we might get
but I like it it's simple
[Music]
I mean maybe there also could be one
registration category just catch-all
category if you're
you know spending raising money to
advance a candidacy or measure measures
and so forth then you can register as a
catch-all be candidate exploratory
candidate candidate committee the all
those terms could be in the same
registration you don't have to pick one
you just pick a list of things right
that's what I was and the same reporting
requirements have applied to
you know so registrant if
in
whatever date January of 2023 just
picking it at random
you want to start publicizing yourself
to people as a candidate whether quite
you know whether broadly or more limited
in a more limited fashion and represent
yourself to them as a candidate and
collect funds from them for that stated
purpose
uh
I gotta think about it more and I think
the idea is if you and if you do that by
spending more than a thousand dollars or
by raising and spending whatever the
number is a thousand twenty five hundred
five thousand whatever you want to set
it at if you raise or spend X then you
have to you know register and Report now
you can get you can take contributions
privately from friends and supporters so
you can say let me give you a
50 bucks to because you to encourage you
to run for office
it's not really until you start this hmm
as a candidate it's only when you spend
a thousand that you have to register and
report right as a candidate committee as
soon as you 48 hours after you start any
activity I think you have to register
and the reporting requirements are a
little different it's exp raising or
spending for a candidate committee and
people think those could just be made
the same and and the thresholds the
raising spending maybe it should be the
same all those things for both
right including the when you need to
register
and to say for what it's worth the FEC
has a very long statement on defining
what we're talking about right
so what Jerry FEC between testing the
waters versus campaigning
we might pick up useful thoughts from
that but yeah it's a long very
interesting thing what you can and can't
do
but we've
my immediate reaction is that we would
not want to bind ourselves to something
that complicated yeah at the stable
thing it's about the whole length of
664.
you're kidding me
pretty long
what is what what he's uh he said it's
the length of the waters for possible
candidates yeah it's pretty long
we just had publicly financed elections
we could solve all of these problems
there you go yeah that would keep the
big money out of politics right you know
the people who print money
hahaha
don't talk about that list yeah that
would be useful I'll do the same I'll
are people comfortable working in a
Google doc in a shared dock have you
done that before if you haven't I'm not
going to introduce you to it but it's a
way it's a fairly easy way of having
multiple contributors I'm not ready to
do that yet
myself
I I would just the way I work I would
prefer to have people share their
thoughts in an independent document that
I can
look at locally without getting into the
cloud it's just you like track changes
well I'm not I'm not I'm not feeling
like I'm at the point where I want to
share it forget about it first yoga then
group Google doc
is that fantasy life of yours again yeah
wow that's very active I hope it's an
enjoyable one
haha
there was one thing that we talked about
was about the required disclosure of
who's paying for things like on the
signs and whatever and do we need the
address and do you
um or do you just put the reference if
there's a website put a website on there
that's already allowed as long as the
website includes the contact information
if you were to sign out you put your
website on it and the website has that
information that's allowable
that's my clear recollection I'm wrong
tell me but okay I'm pretty sure that's
right then wait and then what do you do
do you have to put it on buttons
and then there's the whole thing about
digital ads which Ross was talking about
too what do you do with digital ads yeah
I don't have any feeling for that at
this point okay
and as far when it comes to signs how do
you how practically speaking how do you
enforce that anyway
seriously I mean I've known people I
know people at the local level at least
who aren't even aware of the requirement
and first time I when I ran for
selectman I had I went back and pasted
addresses on all my signs yeah and I
and that's under yeah I mean that would
be under enforcement right good point we
need to talk about you know and I was
surprised to see I think I think I saw
something in here that said if you're if
you haven't filed everything you're not
supposed to be uh
uh you're not really
I think they say you can't I saw that
list in your notes you can't be
nominated or elected if you're behind on
your last
financial and I'm that has not been
enforced I don't think
I saw that in your list I was just
surprised I was like well so this wasn't
that wasn't something you were proposing
that was something you thought you saw
in the IRS in the statute it's in here
yeah
well I bet I bet that would be very
challengable
yeah no candidate she'll be entitled to
the nomination or election until the
sworn itemized statements required to be
filed by him
or they left out her in his behalf have
been filed as required by
yeah but oh that's interesting
yeah because that's definitely not been
enforced
well that would be a good question for a
representative of the Attorney General's
office along with my question about how
you enforce putting contact info on a
sign
right or mailing from out of state
right remember that was the concern you
had
so
um
yeah
okay
well we have time uh yes if you'd like
to ask a question
yeah well having a allowed a member of
the public to to ask a question I have
to make sure that all viewpoints get the
opportunity now since this is a this is
a work session public meeting but not a
public hearing
um just a question I know you had said
you're looking at a total rewrite but
then you had this different ideas
presented and I was just wondering if
you're thinking that the final Pros
product would be one bill with a total
rewrite or if you're thinking that you
know Ross Berry might introduce a bill
that mandates the online system for
certain races and that you all
co-sponsor it and then the other idea
around you know changing the the
definition to make it clear on
you know the date that you file a report
you know is another bill and that you
sort of delegate like representative
Ward is going to take it up to and
including and delete including and and
that's a separate piece of legislation
that you kind of are thinking of you
know each different person Prime
sponsoring a different idea
or are we thinking one one complete and
total massive bill
uh
I can only answer for myself my function
as chairman I think is obvious is to
arrange things like scheduling meetings
and making sure we all have an
opportunity to speak our thoughts that's
you know facilitate the discussion but
speaking for myself I don't have that
level of organization in my thoughts yet
having looked at the number of
uh seemingly minor seemingly minor
issues in the current statutes
my feeling is we go after the things we
can agree to fix and the idea of a total
rewrite sounds too ambitious to me
and how we would organize the
actually trying to make changes by
there may be some things we can agree on
that are simple enough we could get
something prepared
for the next legislative year
uh
but I think probably should keep our
focus on the stated purpose of the the
subcommittee which is to prepare a
report
on recommendations that make sense to
you guys makes sense to me but
okay okay I've said I've spoken for
myself now others we're going to hear
from the others that's an interesting
question
I mean I'm open I'm open to different
strategies once we get to the point
where if we got to the point where the
the committee as a whole is in agreement
about a number of desirable changes then
it just becomes a question of how to
advocate for them and persuade our
colleagues and sometimes dividing things
up into different bills when each one
requires a different argument makes more
sense because you can make the discrete
arguments rather than making 16
arguments about one bill but if there's
a you know series of grammatical fixes
in different sections of the law then
you might bundle those all together and
it would be a true housekeeping Bill
unlike unlike most of the bills that are
yeah then this is only my second term
but I've often heard
that the New Hampshire house does not
like what some call Omnibus bills bills
that have a number of
topics that are not closely related and
I have to say that's my feeling on the
matter too personally so
what representative mirrorhead was just
describing I think is consistent with
you have all of our stuff would be on
campaign Finance true in this chapter so
I don't think of that as an Omnibus Bill
I think that a long complicated bill
I'm concerned about the definitions so
that if we don't get the definitions
passed that we want are these other
bills going to make sense with these
existing so part the yeah part of me is
like we need to clean up some of these
definitions or add them so if we don't
pass them as a package I'm concerned
that we may not solve the issues that we
want to solve
uh
uh that's that's the way I look at
things I mean we all have dealt with
yeah difficult complex problems and I
know in my background sometimes you're
lucky and you can can split these
components into parts that are
independent of each other and and so
address a series of simpler problems I
think that's what you're talking about
I'm sure it's true and must be true in
most
fields
I'm not sure that unless we get all the
definitions right that we can
necessarily peace peace meal it so we
need to kind of think through if we're
going to do it now so you so I would so
you're
prioritize you're you're stating what
you think would be a priority for which
pieces we should deal with first right
last week because I said we're talking
and I was like good boy so you said you
thought what I was like oh boy yeah I
mean right as in that's okay there's a
lot of stuff in here that we've not
talked about so I know
so I'm not sure but I I was thinking we
were doing an Omnibus one but I I
that is intimidating
and I mean go ahead representative Lane
you're you're you know describing a
situation where the different parts of
the bill are logically connected yeah
and where you need to redefine things or
clean up definitions in order to get to
the next thing and have so that would be
that then there's a reason to have
things bundled together and and the less
there's a reason to bundle things
together then maybe we don't bundle them
together but let's be open to whatever
strategy makes things most transparent
to voters to our colleagues and and and
seems just most fair and effective
whatever that is
do you have any thoughts on this
representative Ward at this point you
it's open right
so I think that is a as complete an
answer as we can give to your question
we're working on it
it's only 25 Pages it's not like it's a
big deal excuse me the 664 is only 25
Pages it's not very I'm gonna dump it
into chat GPT tonight and ask chat GPT
to revise it revise the whole thing and
I'll have it by Friday okay
well I I did I did open it to questions
from the public so I am obligated to
make sure that if anyone has another
question they have an opportunity to ask
it so it looks like uh okay sure I mean
yes please and and identify yourself to
us
oh really I've tried it out it's not
that good yes I'm sorry go ahead
uh would you press the button to get the
red light on did you
right in front I knew that
there we go perfect my name is Corrine
Dodge and I live in Derry I don't really
have a question but I want to thank you
for the way you're working together with
one another
um campaign Finance reform has been an
issue for me for a long time ever since
I joined open democracy action and I am
so happy to see
Republicans and Democrats working
together for campaign Finance reform
that's really it's not a question it's
just a statement oh thank you thank you
for that comment and you're welcome
thinking for myself
and I'm sure the areas where we'll have
vigorous discussion will present
themselves at some point but
all right I'm going to uh speaking as
chairman then I'm going to the this
brief period of public comment is now
closed
and thank you I appreciate the interest
we don't have to go to noon if we've run
out of things to talk about now I'm not
urging we stop but I'm perfectly willing
to but I mean I think I have my marching
orders and and it would be
don't have anything else on my agenda
this morning
and I've actually acquired an action
um I was thinking that maybe we could
contact
UM the national what's that legislative
service the National Conference
legislative I can't remember the name
the acronym but they have
materials and stuff
that I thought we might
find useful at least as far as
addressing some of these definitions
and some of the issues that other people
have run into so we don't have to
reinvent the wheel
um would you like me to do that or do
you want to do that yeah I think that
would be I would like you to do that I
think it would be useful for me too okay
if we can uh mine what other people have
done for the things that will work here
in New Hampshire right why
it's been my experience it is easier
it's often easier to recognize a good
it's easier to copy the wheel but to
reinvent
well once an idea exists and it's out
there it's
all right
so do we amongst us feel a need for
okay
then we can if someone would like to
will be semi-formal above someone would
like to ask ask for a motion to adjourn
or just assert my uh I'll tell you what
so moved okay
two weeks same time same place that I'm